MTV has cut ties with Teen Mom 2's
Janelle Evans and have no plans to cover
her story in the upcoming season a
source healthy teeth at Janelle's firing
cane as an unpleasant surprise to the
reality star as she was having ongoing
conversations with production over the
last several weeks about her future with
the network and the show what are we
gonna do
the news comes after allegations that
Janelle's husband David Eason shot and
killed their French Bulldog nugget dude
you should be good David all but
confirmed this claiming the animal
attacked his two-year-old daughter in a
sense deleted video of the dog appearing
aggressive writing I'm all about
protecting my family it is my life's
mission some people are worth killing or
dying for and my family means that much
to me June L shared a tribute post a
nugget writing in part nugget I'm crying
everyday I love you so much and I'm so
sorry I'm speechless
you still had a lot to learn and a lot
to grow from your lessons you're gone
forever and there's no coming back this
is David
MTV previously entered their
relationship with David in February 2018
after he posted a number of homophobic
and transphobic tweets
[Music]
Janell herself has also threatened to
quit the show multiple times as for the
couple's future together our source says
they are still an item and Janelle has
been telling close friends they are
considering marriage counseling et has
reached out to a rep for the couple for
comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]